[Music]
thank you so what is happening now
they want to make sure they suppress
others from quoting this is unfair this
is madness this is not similar session
this is what the core criminality and
the corruption of the highest order when
you have to when you have to diversitize
mass majority of people from voting this
is not good this is not this this should
not do not be accepted in any civilized
society
friends
[Music]
we're also hearing from some politicians
and political parties about concerns
about vote rigging and vote tampering so
some people here are concerned that
could affect the selection and people
are concerned that this election result
when it comes out could be disputed we
could start seeing the final official
result late Monday maybe into Tuesday if
this goes wrong that means that we don't
have a say in our country
foreign
[Music]
whoever wins this election will have a
lot of challenges ahead of them they
have to deal with the economy youth
unemployment corruption and insecurity
in some parts of the country so it's a
wait and see for many people here in
Nigeria
[Music]